are the key excerpts the committee now
says that I deliberately misled the
house and at the moment I spoke I was
consciously concealing from the house my
knowledge of illicit events this is
rubbish it is a lie in order to reach
this deranged conclusion the committee
is obliged to say a series of things
that are patiently absurd or
contradicted by the facts he went on to
say about the committee's decision that
their argument can be boiled down to
look at this picture that's Boris
Johnson with a glass in his hand he must
have known that the event was illegal
therefore he lied that is a load of
complete tripe that picture was me in my
place of work trying to encourage and
thank my officials in a way that I
believed was crucial for the government
and for the country as a whole and in a
way which I believe to be wholly within
the rules he ends by saying this this
report is a charade I was wrong to
believe in the committee or its good
faith the terrible truth is that it is
not I who has Twisted the truth to suit
my purposes it is Harriet Harman and her
committee this is a dreadful day for MPS
and for democracy this decision means
that no MP is free from vendetta or
expulsion on trump top charges by a tiny
minority who want to see him or her gone
from the commons